Salut je vais vous parler aujourd'hui d'une étude scientifique qui confirme et explique
comment on peut déduire la pensée d'une personne en regardant dans ses yeux.
Avec les siens ! Donc si vous la regardez dans les yeux c'est que elle aussi elle sait faire, donc si vous fassiez attention.
Dans une vidéo du mois de juin je vous avez aussi parlé d'une étude qui remettait largement en
question la direction du regard dans l'interprétation qu'on appelait la PNL.
Pas le groupe même s'ils ont une chanson qui s'appelle "Je ne comprends pas"...
Et donc je vous avais proposé qu'on refasse l'étude
ensemble, vous et moi. J'ai les résultats je vais vous donner tout ça dans la deuxième partie de la vidéo
parenthèse rapide en trois mois on est déjà à la septième réédition du livre !
C'est clairement un succès et c'est clairement grâce à vous que c'en est un. Aujourd'hui il est considéré comme un outil pratique et ludique par un
bon nombre de professionnels et particuliers. Alors je profite de cette vidéo de rentrée pour vous dire MERCI !
Et pour ceux qui souhaitent en savoir plus dans la description il y a un lien vers le livre est vers la vidéo de présentation.
Le 15 juin de cette année donc 2017.
Alors oui je donne l'année pour ceux qui regarderaient cette vidéo dans 15 ans en se demandant ce que regardaient leurs parents avant.
Parce que c'est ça qui va se passer un jour ! En juin dernier le CNRS, le Centre National de Recherche Scientifique
a publié un communiqué de presse qui s'intitule: "Ce que les pupilles nous disent sur le langage". Depuis longtemps peut-être toujours
où je sais pas quand parce que je trouve pas forcément de date
au début de cette pratique... les mentalistes partent du principe que la pensée peut générer une réaction dans le regard.
Un petit peu comme le réflexe de Pavlov et qu'est ce que c'est le réflexe de Pavlov ?
Ben écoutez je suis vous le dire ! [imitation Sarkozy]
C'est très simple Ivan Petrovitch Pavlov a démontré que si il répétait le même
stimulus à chaque fois qu'il apportait de la nourriture à un chien, comme par exemple siffler dans un...
sifflet...! Quel suspense ! Alors à terme le fait de faire ce stimulus sans forcément apporter la nourriture en même temps
déclencher la salivation du chien.
Mais cet exemple c'était pour vous puissiez bien comprendre l'idée, parce qu'en réalité le réflexe de Pavlov est un réflexe conditionné
qu'on appelle maintenant le conditionnement de Pavlov.
Revenons-en au mentalisme; je disais donc, les mentalistes partent du principe que la pensée peu générer une réaction dans le regard
Oui j'ai honteusement repris le même plan que tout à l'heure.
A un détail près...
Ou pas !
Ou alors j'ai fait mon fénéant.
On va y arriver je disais les mentalistes part du principe que la pensée peut générer une réaction dans
le regard, mais c'est uniquement lié à l'expérience des mentalistes et non à un protocole scientifique.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'empirisme
et je vous propose une source dans la description très intéressante et très philosophique à ce sujet. A ce jour ce que les mentalistes
pratiquaient et donc de manière empirique vient d'être validé scientifiquement par des chercheurs du laboratoire de psychologie cognitive et par ceux du laboratoire
parole et langage du CNRS Aix Marseille Université, ainsi que par l'université
Groningen du Pays-Bas et je sais pas si ça se prononce comme ça... Ils ont démontré que la taille des pupilles n'est pas forcément
liée qu'à la lumière ambiante ou à l'intensité lumineuse de l'objet qu'on regarde, mais aussi et ça c'est génial
au mot utilisé à l'écrit comme à l'oral. Si je vous dis par exemple: "Une grande plage à midi baignée d'un soleil éblouissant."
Alors votre pupille va se contracter même si vous êtes dans un endroit sombre. A l'inverse si je vous dis: "En pleine nuit ou dans l'obscurité."
Alors votre pupille va donc réagir comme si elle était dans le noir et se dilater.
Pour quantifier scientifiquement cela, les chercheurs ont donc fait lire puis entendre à 60 personnes
30 noms lumineux, 30 mots on va dire "obscures" et 30 mots neutres en termes de luminosité comme ballon pob,
pouces bleus... je crois que ça s'est vu là... Et enfin ils l'auront fait lire et entendre 20 noms d'animaux.
En parallèle les chercheurs ont mesuré la taille des pupilles des participants, oui, parce que sinon ça n'avait aucun intérêt de faire ça !
Sur ce schéma vous pouvez voir comment la pupille réagie face à un mot évoquant une luminosité faible ou élevée.
Et voici quelques plans que je me suis également amusé à filmer en disant d'abord des mots lumineux
puis ensuite des mots sombres, sachant plus que pour faire ces scènes là nous étions en pleine lumière !
Reste maintenant à répondre à une autre question
scientifiquement parlant: Est-ce que les pensées et les images que nous nous faisons
mentalement, sont nécessaires à la compréhension d'un mot ? Là j'en ai déjà perdu 2, 3... Ou sont elles simplement une préparation de
l'organisme est donc une conséquence indirecte ? Les chercheurs sont sur le coup et je peux vous dire qu'ils cherchent c'est que ça c'est le principe, en fait...!
Je suivrai ça de près je vous tiendrai au courant. Si c'est intéressant de voir que la science vient de valider une technique
de mentalisme, parfois c'est l'inverse puisque en 2012 des chercheurs de l'université de Portsmouth avaient invalidé l'un des principes de la PNL.
En demandant à 31 personnes de parler de leur vrai métier,
puis en leur demandant de mentir consciemment et en s'inventant un nouveau métier. Seulement 10% des participants
avaient fait quelque chose qui aurait pu être prédit par la PNL au niveau du mouvement de la direction de leur regard.
C'est-à-dire que le postulat de la PNL c'était de dire que ça partait grosso modo vers la gauche qu'on allait dans sa mémoire, donc quand on disait
la vérité, et vers la droite quand on allait dans la créativité donc quand on inventait. Et c'est là que vous est proposé à vous de faire vous même l'expérience
sur quelqu'un et de mettre les résultats dans un tableau que j'avais mis en ligne que si vous étiez sûr de vos résultats.
Alors on ne va pas se mentir le protocole est léger, bien sûr il peut y avoir un biais de la part de
l'expérimentateur, mais ces résultats que je vous mets en libre accès aussi dans la description ont le mérite d'exister grâce à 558 d'entre vous. Merci !
Pour la première étape, à savoir dire son vrai métier 151 personnes ont regardé vers leur gauche comme la PNL peut
le prédire, soit 27 % des participants. Pour la deuxième étape c'est le moment où l'on fait preuve de créativité
203 personnes ont regardé vers leur droite. Non je me trompe 205 soit 37 % des participants.
Alors les résultats sont quand même plus satisfaisants que dans l'expérience sur 31 personnes en 2012.
Mais il faut prendre en compte que notre protocole fait à distance de cette manière n'est pas très rigoureux.
Disons que ces résultats-là sont informatifs et surtout ils démontrent qu'on est loin de s'approcher d'un pourcentage fiable de quelque chose qu'on pourrait considérer comme étant fiable.
En clair cette méthode peut donner au mieux une
piste à recouper au minimum avec deux autres méthodes plus fiables  et sinon on peut ranger clairement cette théorie aux
oubliettes au rang des idées reçues !
[Max Bird] "Cui cui !
Ha pardon ! J'ai cru qu'on m'avait appelé pardon ! Salut Fabien !"
et donc comme je vous l'ai annoncé je vous mets les résultats des
558 participants dans un tableau qui est dans la description. Comme quoi c'est intéressant de se tenir au courant
des études qui sont réalisées chaque jour en parlant d'ailleurs de faire attention, je n'ai pas utilisé trois fois la même séquence vidéo dans cette
vidéo où on a l'impression que je la réutilise trois fois. En fait c'est un détail près à chaque fois on verra dans les commentaires
si vous trouvez... Et j'ai une surprise pour vous pour cette rentrée je prends trois rendez-vous avec vous ! Oui monsieur oui mademoiselle !
Une nouvelle vidéo tous les mardis à 15H et tous les vendredis à 15H ! Oui à 15H.
Donc ça c'est les deux premiers les mardis et les vendredis à 15H et également un Live à chaque dernier mercredi du mois à 20H20.
20H20 les vrais savent ! Donc le prochain Live ce sera le 27 septembre à 20H20 et on fera un jeu
vraiment un truc interactif tous ensemble j'espère que vous serez là j'ai hâte !
N'oubliez pas que vous pouvez vous abonner même en cliquant sur ce petit rond, même depuis votre téléphone, votre tablette, ça c'est possible.
Et notez le ! Maintenant on se retrouve les mardis et les vendredis à 15H !
Ciao !
[musique générique de fin]